working from home is great working from
a boat is even better until you need to
venture out in search of a 4G connection
reconvene quickly with the icarus line
thrower it's most dangerous object in
the office this moment this eight point
eight pound waterproof canister is
standard equipment on large ocean
vessels it uses seven point eight ounces
of solid rocket fuel to launch a safety
line almost 1,000 feet good for reeling
in struggling swimmers or disabled boats
to operate simply pull the safety pin
steady it against your thigh to cushion
the recoil and pull the trigger the four
millimeter nylon rope can hold up to 450
pounds of data hungry shipwreck
survivors just be sure you have decent
aim
you